wir sind unterwegs richtung don jetzt im
südosten der ukraine
ihr solltet roma kennenlernen hatte uns
ein stabsarzt im militärkrankenhaus in
sapporo schier gesagt sie sei eine ganz
außergewöhnliche krankenschwester die
soldaten verehrten sie wie eine mutter
20 kilometer vor der front erreichen wir
ein feld hospital wo verwundete soldaten
erstversorgt werden
dort erwartet sie uns ich heiße rom
maske seit 35 jahren arbeite ich als
krankenschwester ich bin hier weil ich
der ukraine dienen will hochleben die
helden der ukraine ich bin in
tadschikistan geboren und war dann in
afghanistan tätig später sind wir in der
ukraine als flüchtlinge angekommen
einige haben uns nicht gleich akzeptiert
aber als der krieg angefangen hat habe
ich verstanden dass hier mein vaterland
ist seit 32 jahren bin ich nun in der
ukraine
und jetzt will ich auch etwas
zurückgeben
die verwundeten kommen direkt von der
front
die schwerst verletzten versorgt ein
team aus anästhesisten und chirurgen wie
es zur verwundung kam wäre der patient
ist wissen sie oft nicht
ja
manche soldaten waren wochen oder monate
an der front bevor sie eine verwundung
hierher brachte
roma empfängt sie wie söhne die endlich
nach hause gekommen sind
komm mit mir im zimmer sieben kannst du
dich aus
wir haben auch was zu essen
man kann ich nach hause
ich werde dich abends mit dem auto nach
hause fahren
mädels gebt ihm was zu essen gibt ihm
was zu trinken gibt ihm lassen socken
und eine hose badet ihn wäre hast du
verstanden und in zehn minuten sehe ich
dich hier wieder
am vormittag kommen die verletzten der
nacht heute einer nach dem andern
schmerz nichts als schmerz ich versuche
es mit hey söhnchen alles wird wieder
gut du bist doch der beste wenn einer
weint dann weine ich mit ihm ich nehme
ihn an meine brust und sage ihm dass
alles vorbei gehen wird
dieser kommandeur lag mit seiner truppe
die ganze nacht unter beschuss bevor
einen verwundeten soldaten evakuieren
konnte
ein alter mann wie ich sollte um diese
uhrzeit nicht arbeiten müssen sonst hat
das schlechte laune das bin ich ja
gewöhnt konnte er denn auch nicht
schlafen das waren noch mehr die bis 4
uhr morgens kein auge zugetan haben
fertig die socken sind sauber die schuhe
sind neu auch das t shirt ist neu
bekommt er auch neue unterhosen die
dürfen wir nicht wechseln lassen sich
auf kommandeur die werden mich noch hier
behalten
sascha du wirst noch betteln dass du
wieder in meiner einheit kommen darfst
[Musik]
sind die schwerverletzten stabilisiert
blutungen gestellt und frakturen fixiert
kommen die verwundeten in die militär
krankenhäuser von sapori cia oder nitro
alles muss schnell gehen doch roman
nimmt sich immer zeit für die sorgen und
ängste der soldaten
komiker hier sind die röntgenbilder
hier ist das bild von deiner kugel
ich wünschte ich könnte wenigen bilder
lesen keine sorge du bist du schon sehen
da ist es dieses funktion siehst du das
ist die kugel ja jetzt sehe ich es das
ist von der anderen seite
genau und das gute ist dass der knochen
nicht verletzt wurde
über wenig schweigt die ukrainische
regierung mehr als über die zahl ihrer
gefallenen
schätzungen gehen von 200 toten pro tag
aus wie lange noch wird die armee diese
enormen verluste ersetzen können ich
wünschte es gäbe mehr leute wie uns der
krieg schweißt zusammen er bringt uns
näher aber eher spaltet auch manche
sprechen groß ist andere ukraine china
und der ukraine sind in der unterzahl
und deshalb müssen wir stark sei
[Musik]
denn wir link der russischen armee der
durchbruch kann die front nicht gehalten
werden dann bleibt für die familien hier
nur die flucht
[Musik]
es ist schwer zu schlafen wenn ständig
die sirenen heulen und wenn man wie
heute auf die explosionen hört in meinen
gedanken bin ich dann bei den soldaten
bei ihren eltern ihr schmerz ist auch
mein schmerz
trotz der nächtlichen feuergefechte
beginnt der nächste tag ruhig
womacka ist erleichtert denn heute hat
sie einen besonderen termin
drei gehen wir in die kirche und
anschließend was essen in einem
restaurant
soll ich meine militär uniform anziehen
ja sicher
ich habe eben hier im krankenhaus
getroffen ich sah diesen schweigsamen er
hatte tränen in den augen ich ging zu
ihm hin und fragte hey soldat was ist
passiert er antwortete mein letzter
bruder ist heute gestorben von heute an
bin ich an weise ich sagte willst du
mein sohn sein er sagte nicht lass mich
darüber nachdenken sondern einfach nur
ja ich will
wie sieht mein kleid aus
[Musik]
deine paten eltern werden dir helfen
dich unterstützen und je den weg weisen
lasset uns für eine gute sache bieten
ja gut
die fans heimat ist nur wenige kilometer
jenseits der front doch solange die
ukrainische armee die gebiete nicht
zurück erobert hat wird hier sein neues
zuhause sein
[Musik]
eigentlich wollten sie noch gemeinsam
essen gehen doch roma bekommt einen
anruf
1 200 da ist angekommen oleg hast du
heute dienst mit mir maxi okay er soll
mich anrufen
das krankenhaus hat angerufen 1 200
transport ist angekommen das ist der
code für einen toten soldaten
sie haben gesagt ich soll sofort kommen
halte hier an ich ziemlich schnell um
ein kleiner fisch hast du in mir
gebracht jawohl meine liebe
wir brauchen die listen der
krankenhäuser es gibt noch weitere
verletzte im bataillon
keinen der toten soldaten hat thomas da
vergessen heute ist es ihr 295
[Musik]
ob bosnien lobt das ist meine pflicht
mich um die 200 zu kümmern unsere
gefallenen söhne
diese verfluchten bomben der russen
überall bombensplitter
einer kam von links und hat die
halsschlagader getroffen
geht gar nicht so sehr ums waschen der
leichen sondern vielmehr darum den toten
ihre menschlichkeit zurückzugeben
manchmal sagt rogawska kommen nur
leichenteile
dann versucht sie über tätowierungen
muttermale oder ringe die identität der
toten zu bestimmen
bevor sie sie den angehörigen übergibt
ich begleiche meine schuld ich gehe auf
die knie und sage danke als du hier
warst war ich in sicherheit meine
familie konnte unter einem friedlichen
himmel schlafen ich konnte in frieden
leben weil du dein leben für mich
gegeben hast für mich und meine kinder
und deren kinder deshalb bin ich hier
das ist meine geschichte eine kleine
front geschichte es lebe die ukraine es
leben unsere helden
[Musik]